hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
french science fiction movie called how
i became a superhero
the movie starts by showing a policeman
named moreau
suddenly he is called by his senior to
handle our arson case in a club but it
turns out that he is too late to go
there making a bad first impression on
his new co-worker he is even scolded by
the police chief for his performance as
a result the chief recruits a lieutenant
named schultzman to become his partner
the first impression between them is not
good especially schultzman who does not
like moroes behavior earlier
shortly after they get an emergency call
for a hostage case at a school
the situation at the school is very
chaotic because there is a student who
can shoot out fire from his hands
besides him there is also a student
named lily who looked very difficult to
control her own power at that time
after the police arrive they immediately
think that the boy was the mastermind
behind the previous arson incident while
the other policemen plot their arrest
strategy morrow casually approaches the
boy and carries no weapons at all
he slowly calms the boy until he calms
down
with the opportunity morrow and other
police officers arrest the boy quickly
from that incident the police find two
strange objects that are suspicious
after further investigation it turns out
that the previous arson case was not the
work of the boy so they conclude that
there is someone else who has the exact
same power as the boy
in another place there is a teenager who
is transacting the strange objects it is
revealed that the strange object is a
forbidden substance that can give
ordinary people superpowers
therefore the other teenagers are very
interested in buying the substance
because these superpowers can make them
look cooler
meanwhile moro chose to part with
schultzman to meet his best friend monte
carlo he used to be a superhero who
often helped society and was admired by
many people
he was joined by two other superheroes
named kalista and gigaman and they
finally became a trio called pack royal
however due to his old age he has left
his career when he was a superhero he
met and worked with moreau that's what
makes them still close to this day there
moro wants to ask him for help to
investigate the arson case after reading
his notebook he names bracero as a
candidate for the arson case earlier
without further ado moreau immediately
rushes to find brucero there is a
research headquarters led by someone
named naja it is the research base that
produces illicit substances and is also
traded among the teenagers
the next day the police held a meeting
related to the arson case
just in time morrow tells the rest of
the police about bracero
now bracero has finally been named as a
temporary suspect in the arson case
thus the police chief immediately
directs all teams to look for bracero
after that monty calls moro to tell him
that bracero is currently working at a
restaurant in paris
the scene moves to calista who is now
working as a basketball teacher she has
a super power to see at a glance what
will happen to a person in the future
at the same time moro visits her and
asks her about bracero
unexpectedly it turns out that she knows
bracero quite well
moro then asks for her help to find
bursaro but unfortunately she refuses
he still doesn't give up and continues
his investigation with schultzman
later they go to the hospital where the
arson victims are being treated the
doctor tells them that one person has
already died
surprisingly it turns out that the
patient is bracero who is a victim of
the illicit substance
the doctor also suspects that the
substance is made of human blood knowing
the information they have to find the
real mastermind
that night they chose to stay up late
and look at the cctv photos at the scene
from the photo morrow accidentally finds
one person who managed to escape from
the place they also continue their
search to every hospital treating the
arson victims
after a while they are able to find the
boy
the boy apparently ran away and chose to
be treated at a different hospital from
the other victims
it certainly makes them suspicious about
him they immediately interrogate the boy
forcing him to admit who the dealer is
by telling what happened to bracero he
finally says that someone named ishmael
has sold the substance outside his
school
sure enough he is one of naija's
subordinates but on the other hand he
turns out to be secretly carrying some
substances and disappears from nage's
base
naja also suspects that he would betray
him so he immediately orders the rest of
his men to find ishmael
the scene moves to ishmael who is
walking towards somewhere
at that place the police are waiting for
him knowing he is about to be arrested
he tries to escape from that place
moro and schultzman quickly chase after
him
with good cooperation they managed to
catch him in a store
after that he is directly interrogated
by moroe and his team but he chooses to
remain silent the police are getting
confused
on the other hand moro gets information
from monty about a man named eclipso who
has a superpower to make others blind
instantly they suspect that maybe that
person has something to do with their
case a few moments later eclipso attacks
the police station he is assisted by
some of naija's men so that they can
free ishmael
some police officers experience
temporary blindness
morrow also meets schultzman who is also
blinded causing her to fall down
it is revealed that moreau has a
superpower to move or lift objects with
his hands which is also known as
telekinesis he uses his superpower
urgently to save schulzmann
meanwhile ishmael is immediately taken
away by naj's men
at his base naja wants to kill him with
his own hands but before that he tells
najib that he saw a policeman who has
superpower this information catches
naj's attention and immediately sends
his men to look for moro
at the same time kalista has a vision
about two of her students who are about
to die from the substance they will die
because of the prototype substance newly
developed by naja and the substances
given to them for free they don't know
that they are just guinea pigs
it turns out the substance was developed
by naja from the blood of a kidnapped
girl named lily she is the daughter of
gigaman and the superpower that is in
her body is none other than the
descendants of his deceased father
moreau who knows this is very angry and
immediately investigates the kidnapping
unfortunately in the middle of his
investigation he is kidnapped and
drugged by some of naij's men
luckily in his unconscious state he is
still able to unleash his superpower and
makes the card damaged due to the
pressure from his hands
at the right time lena and calista come
to save morrow but as a result of the
incident he is shot three times in the
chest and suffers serious injuries
and again he uses his power to remove
the bullets so that the healing process
can be done faster they bring him to
monty's place to be treated
there kalista has just revealed the fact
that moro is a superhero like pack
royale but there was an incident that
separates them morrow who at that time
was still unable to fully control his
power accidentally made a mistake while
trying to arrest a criminal his mistake
results in gigaman's death
because of it he never uses his powers
again
but now they agree to unite to save lily
and capture naja while waiting for
mauro's condition to improve they
initially conduct an investigation and
finally they managed to find naj's
headquarters
from a scientist they discover the
reason why naja is behaving like this
it turns out that in the past he was
also used as an object of research for
people who have superpowers
therefore he suffers from a mental
disorder that causes him to want revenge
at this time
while moro hasn't recovered the
substance is still there and even used
by a group of people to commit theft and
murder in the end the group decides to
attack naj's headquarters together with
the police of course without moreau
naja orders his men to bring all the
substances he has and also he brings
lily to escape from that place
because of these substances naij's men
also have superpowers
fortunately there is a monty who can
teleports instantly in the meantime neja
takes lily through a different path with
his men but suddenly he is blocked by
moreau he makes naja more challenged so
that he inhales more of the substance to
make him stronger when he is caught off
guard moro manages to get rid of him and
tell schultzman to take lily to a safer
place
he then continues his duel with naja who
continuously inhales the substance until
it makes him uncontrollable moro uses
the opportunity to take him as far as
possible and makes him shattered and
explode in the sky
at first people thought the explosion
also killed moreau but gladly he
survived the incident the film ends
happily with the arson case solved and
lilly saved morrow also starts to accept
himself as a superhero
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching